joining us now senate judiciary
committee chairman he'll be presiding
over all of this lindsey graham senator
welcome to the program
it's interesting how all the precedent
was broken by them
right now they're threatening what's
back to court
right it's pretty obvious they want an
outcome they'll destroy anybody's life
to keep these seats open they said they
tried to destroy brett kavanaugh so they
could feel the seat they were dumb
enough to say that
i've seen this movie before it's not
going to work
it didn't work with kavanaugh we've got
the votes to confirm
justice ginsburg replacement before the
election we're going to move forward in
the committee we're going to report the
nomination
out of the committee to the floor of the
united states senate so we can vote
before the election
that's the constitutional process after
kavanaugh
everything changed with me they're not
going to intimidate me mitch mcconnell
or anybody else
i'm getting outraged three to one
outspent four to one if you want to help
me fight back
go to lindsey graham.com five or ten
bucks from half your audience would fill
in the gap that i'm facing
but we're going to have a process that
you'll be proud of
the nominee is going to be supported by
every republican
in the judiciary committee and we've got
the votes to confirm the judge
the justice on the floor of the senate
before the election and that's what's
coming
senator they want to stack the court
they want to end the filibuster for even
legislation they're talking about
impeaching the president impeaching the
attorney general
all the precedent had been broken so far
by democrats
um now they're going to take it to this
level do you
because they've already done it before
why would they why would we not believe
them now
name one liberal justice nominated by a
democrat that had their life ruined
they're talking about changing the
electoral college if they keep the house
the senate and the white house this
country will change fundamentally
the electoral college will be
obliterated will go to a popular
vote d.c and uh the puerto rico will
become states so be 104 senators
uh it goes on and on and on there'll be
additional members of the supreme court
they'll all be liberal they're going to
take the process the rules and change
them to their benefit now the only thing
stopping them
is you the voter if you want to help me
and other republicans get into the game
they're killing us financially
i'm in south carolina not exactly a
liberal state
my opponent's going to raise 80 million
dollars i need conservatives
to help me you need to help us all
lindsey graham.com
oh by the way barbara streisand rosie
o'donnell uh
they want to tell south carolina how to
vote all right senator thank you we'll
be watching and having you back on as we
move in this
process